hi Matt here before we start our latest
episode we wanted to let you know that
we now have a think fast talk smart the
newsletter we'll provide bonus content
additional materials like articles and
videos previews of future topics and
behind the scenes information please
sign up at
stanford.io
TF TS newsletter again stanford.io slash
tfts newsletter also join us on
Instagram we started a new account think
fast talk smart follow us there just
like you follow us on LinkedIn
communication can be very challenging
especially when others don't see the
world the way we do
today we'll discuss how to bridge that
Gap
[Music]
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
I am very excited to talk today with
Seema Yasmin a collaborator and friend
SEMA is the director of the Stanford
health communication initiative and a
clinical assistant professor of medicine
at the Stanford Medical School
SEMA is an assistant professor of Crisis
communication and crisis management at
the Anderson School of Management at
UCLA she is a doctor an Emmy
award-winning journalist and the author
of Five Books her latest of which is
called what the fact welcome SEMA thanks
for being here thank you for having me
Matt it's great to talk to you yeah the
last time we talked I was actually being
interviewed by you for some video we
were doing so I'm glad that the tables
are a bit turned you get to enact your
revenge it was it was a pleasure I'm
ready for it okay give me your worth I'm
gonna give you my best uh let's get
started um as I've gotten to know you
over all these years one thing I is very
clear to me you are a master
Communicator you write you teach you
coach and you've even done a little bit
of stand-up comedy I'm curious if you
have any overarching approach to your
communication any guiding principles you
use empathy and respect for your
audience so knowing your audience
understanding what their expertise is
because they're experts in things you're
not and then connecting with your
audience through empathy and compassion
that is at the heart of my communication
strategies I absolutely have seen that
play out when I've seen you teach you
really are empathetic much of your work
focuses on communication and health care
or about Healthcare topics what lessons
do you teach Health Care Professionals
like doctors and nurses and can you
relate those lessons to those of us
outside of Health Care I remind them I
would say I suggest guide and remind
that you don't know it all and that
might sound really simple but it's quite
humbling and sometimes difficult for
people to hear and that they will walk
in to the room that I am in with their
arms crossed and sometimes we'll even
say I just don't think there's anything
else you could teach me about
communication and they have decade Aids
on me sometimes and they do know things
that I don't know but they need a
reminder that there's new evidence on
Communications or there are just some
better strategies out there that they
might use so that's one of the things I
am reminding people of we all suffer
from that curse of knowledge and it can
be threatening to realize that we don't
know everything
oftentimes Healthcare professionals are
in a position to be encouraging attitude
and behaviors in people who might not
want to take them on for example no that
never happens
this is easy yeah I mean eat less or eat
differently exercise more can you
provide some insight into how we can
motivate people to do things that they
may not want to do or feel capable of
doing yeah Behavior change is like the
Cornerstone of all of this and I've
literally just come off the phone with
an auntie who lives across an ocean who
won't get her flu shot because the
covert vaccine caused all these problems
and I'm like no it didn't and like you
really need your flu shot so to that
point I'm going to have a different
conversation with her than I am with my
friend who's got a drph from Harvard who
also doesn't want to get their flu shot
they have two very different reasonings
and what often happens in medicine and
perhaps at large and you might know more
about that at is this idea that I have a
message I want to get across the message
is going to help you it will aim to
convince you to get vaccinated but it
does none of the intelligence gathering
or the listening at the beginning that
Garners the information you need to
effectively communicate with a person
even just to understand why does my
auntie really passionately not want the
flu shot and why does my friend over in
Cambridge not want the flu shot
completely different reasons and
therefore I'm going to use quite
different approaches so what I'm hearing
is a couple things you have to really
think about what's motivating the
behavior or lack of the behavior and the
attitudes that go with it and then you
have to craft messaging that's different
and specific so there's no peanut butter
approach where you just spread the same
message across and you really have to
focus
that requires a lot of effort and time
yes it does and it should that this is
not an easy fix and in the context of
coaching I do whether it's with
physician leaders or clinicians at large
people will come in with that tell me
what I can do in the context of an
eight-minute consult and I'm like I get
it because I've been there 12 minutes is
hard eight minutes is horrible what can
you do in that eight minutes to convince
my auntie for example if you're her GP
to get the flu shot probably not going
to convince her to get the flu shot but
you might convince her to come in the
next month for another blood sugar check
you might convince her that you're
actually a really open-minded person who
won't berate her for her particular
belief and her experience and many will
tell you this has been I'm not even
going to share this information with you
about my belief on the science on the
vaccine stuff because I just know you're
gonna tell me I'm silly and I should
just do a thing so my advice often to
people is it's not going to be a one and
done conversation realistically what can
you do in that first conversation in
that eight minutes and that 80 minutes
whatever you have that can leave the
door open for further communication
I hear two things though that are really
important one it's about the connection
and the relationship that you build and
there's an incremental approach that you
have to think about over the long term
how can I move this person in that
direction I think we have become very
transactional we want it right now and
when it comes to attitudinal change and
behavioral change it might take time oh
my gosh especially when you remind
yourself and I go into the detail of
this in what the fact
belief is not just about fact this is
why a conversation with my aunt for
example with somebody about vaccines can
get so heated in it's not really about
the vaccine our belief is so much to do
with our belonging to a community our
belief is so deeply intertwined with our
identity so when you're saying to
someone I disagree with you about your
perspective on masks actually there's a
whole set of clouds around them that are
geopolitics history language dialect
culture faith family history
hierarchies in their community and yet
we're just talking about the vaccine and
we're just talking about the 16
ingredients in the vial I promise you
many times that is not going to work
because you're erasing all the rest of
that person you're neglecting the fact
that what they believe is entrenched in
them and it's to do with their sense of
belonging and their sense of identity a
lot of that doesn't make sense when you
think about it from an intellectualist
point of view you but it makes complete
sense when you think about it from an
interactionist point of view and you
talk to The evolutionary biologist who
remind us hey you're alive today because
your ancestors a long time ago were able
to survive predatory species by banding
together that belonging really occurred
because of shared beliefs it was wrapped
up in our survival
you are reminding us of something that
has been mentioned a few times on this
podcast about we have to understand the
entirety of the situation that the
person is in that we're communicating
with not just the specific issue and you
also highlight the notion between
understanding and agreeing I can
understand your perspective but I don't
necessarily have to agree with your
perspective and when we come from that
position I think it opens up
collaboration and dialogue that often
gets shut off so let's get to what's the
fact when it comes to fake news and
extreme ideas and positions do you have
any advice on how we can effectively
debunk those lies or distorted truths
that others in our lives hold to be true
what can we do to help reduce the
difference between us and them there's a
lot of research on this and it's
fascinating and I'm sure you've heard or
already spoken about the illusion of
explanatory depth but let me share that
as one great strategy because I love
this story it's the idea that often the
people who hold the strongest views
they're the most passionate about
something when asked well how do tax
policies to cut carbon emissions really
work might be the same folks who are
like
um uh I um I don't know and I don't say
this again because compassion empathy
hello not saying it to shame anyone
because shame actually not helpful
motivator but if you can do that kind of
probing gently compassionately guiding
somebody to a place of oh crap I don't
actually understand how this works can
be really helpful from dislodging them
from their polarized corner and the
example I use when I do Keynotes where I
do coaching is I think it was Yale
students were asked
how does a flush toilet work do you know
how it works everyone's like well yeah
and you use it like three times a day I
know what okay well can you explain how
the cistern and the ball and and people
are like
um yeah no many of us use things daily
the internet flush toilets very basic
very modern we don't fully know how they
work and so this brings me to a second
point one understanding the illusion of
explanatory depth the fact that hey we
had really strong beliefs on things we
actually don't know much about but it
also brings me to that point of you
don't have to understand how everything
works in order to have some sense of
knowledge about well I know flush
toilets work man like I use them it's
fine on these on everything I know there
are people on the planet who are experts
in systems and the mechanics of a flush
toilet because of the internet perhaps
and because of like the way we share
knowledge I don't always know where my
understanding ends and theirs begins
that's okay but let's be much more aware
of that and again it brings me back to
that interactionist point of view which
is related to compassion and empathy
because it reminds us that there is
collective knowledge and Collective
belief that guides us to sometimes
thinking we know it all I'm smiling
because before we talked I said we
better make sure that we use clean
language and it turns out you ended up
being a potty mouth but in a very
different very different way this this
idea of
gradually or incrementally helping
people see that they might not be
experts I can understand how that could
really help open people up I can only
imagine that you have to be very careful
in that Journey because if you come on
too strong too fast it can be really
challenging and one way of doing that is
perhaps sharing your lack of
understanding and actually asking them
in a genuinely curious way like do you
think between the two of us we could
actually figure out how a flush toilet
works or even how tax policies to cut
carbon emissions like if you were
designing it how would you do it like
how do they do it now it's okay to not
know I think it comes back to that
humility too but it brings me to another
point that I make in what the fact your
beliefs about things do not have to be
binary black and white and on off switch
right that's actually oftentimes pretty
dangerous place to be because then you
are in that polarized Corner that no one
can dislodge you from
If instead you say to yourself I'm going
to assign levels of credence to beliefs
about things then when someone gently
compassionately kindly guides you to do
you know how that tax policy works
because I don't right then you might say
oh crap yeah no I don't either I'm gonna
bring that belief that I really love
those tax policies or really hate them
gonna bring it down a couple of notches
and what that does is it allows you to
then take in and absorb new evidence
which you can then assess discuss decide
and then you can reassess and you can
change your level of credence about that
belief so it's actually something that's
that idea that strategy is something
that's known to be cognitively building
resilience mental resilience to
polarization mental resilience to
staunchly believing something and not
being open to push back
I find that idea of resilience
fascinating and one that we should all
think about how that knowledge can help
us when we are in the position of trying
to convince somebody of something but
also just for ourselves where are we and
I really resonated with that notion that
our attitudes are not necessarily binary
they're on a Continuum and I fear that
when somebody comes on strong opposed to
one of your beliefs or attitudes that
you Retreat to a more extreme point of
view than you might actually have
because we're being challenged so
reminding ourselves that there's a
gradation of our attitudes and beliefs
and reminding ourselves that if we come
on too strong we can push people farther
away because it feels like an attack
against who you are not just your belief
for or against vaccines or for or
against a particular presidential
candidate so we have to remember that
that's why that's happening yes yeah and
again it's a it's a threat to who we see
ourselves as and our belonging to the
culture and the environment that we live
in so let me ask you this is it possible
to BS proof our brains in other words
what critical thinking skills do we need
to develop to avoid being victimized by
fake news and inappropriate information
it is possible this book is very
Solutions oriented and has a whole
chapter about what you're asking me
about one of those things of course is
what we've just discussed this idea that
don't have uh black and white binary
ideas about belief instead of this on
off switch have this dimmer switch right
that's the visual image that builds um
cognitive resilience too the inoculation
theory is fascinating to me because it's
this idea that came about in social
psychology in the 1960s it's not new and
it came about from a Harvard social
psychologist called William McGuire so
what Bill did is he used a medical idea
and he thought hold on if I can protect
you from getting very sick with flu by
exposing you to a small amount or
weakened version of flu why can't I do
the same with propaganda why can't I do
the same with the disinformation and so
he tested this hypothesis he exposed
people to a weakened version of a lie
and it did in fact work you give someone
a heads up in the first place hey you
know what we're developing a vaccine at
warp speed there's every chance that we
might get a vaccine for this new
infection quicker than we've ever made a
vaccine
I already know that if that happens
someone's going to say to you it
happened too quickly to be safe someone
else is going to say it makes you
magnetic someone else is going to say
there's a microchip in it and Bill Gates
is trying to track us all etc etc what
that does when I tell you that
it gives you this mental heads up an
alarm Bell like oh crap someone's going
to be targeting me with these lies then
what I do is I say to you here's why
that's not true like a vaccine can't
make you magnetic because Bill Gates is
not putting microchips in them because
and yeah it's being made really quickly
but here's why it's still safe look at
what they're doing
that in the person who is exposed to it
develops mental counter arguments where
they build what we're calling these
mental antibodies like the same that you
have in your immune system but this time
kind of around your brain I think
inoculation theory is fascinating and
have studied it and and read up on it
and I think it's highly ironic that
we're using inoculation Theory to talk
about inoculations just putting those
two together it was brilliant the idea
of pre-exposing people before they
actually get it and preparing them for
how to respond is very very powerful
we'll see before we end I'd like to ask
you the same three questions I ask
everybody who joins me are you up for
that yes excellent question number one
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would that be know your
audience so three words but honestly I
just see that not done and that one size
fits-all message lob to everyone every
audience is not the same please adjust
your messaging very consistent you've
been talking about empathy and the need
to really reflect and and knowing your
audience is absolutely critical I'm
going to be really curious to hear your
answer for this given that I know you
well I'm curious who you're going to
pick but who is a communicator that you
admire and why
I want to say my mother that's fine tell
me more about why my mother Yasmin
Halima is expert at knowing her audience
and slipping into you know code
switching and doing her research
beforehand and understanding power
hierarchies whether they're in a 10 000
person non-profit or in my family which
is perhaps more complicated than the ten
thousand person non-profit believe it or
not and I just see her work wonders
against people who might be very
entrenched in their beliefs
sure so the Apple has not Fallen far
from the tree you are an expert
Communicator don't cook as good as there
I don't know if I can communicate as
good as her but it's a good role model
well that's it we should all have role
models and it's nice that you have one
in your family
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe you are or I didn't know well I
know at least one or two of them what
give me all three the listeners right
now could probably just get she's gonna
say compassion I am she's gonna say
empathy yes I am and the third one for
successful communication
honesty and fun
you hyphenated it to sneak it in yeah so
I I can completely see how Candor and
honesty is very important talk to me
about fun because a lot of the topics
you write about and you talk about
they're not really fun in some cases
they're life and death no some of them
how do you keep your positive
perspective when you're dealing with
some of these really challenging issues
I've taken up trampolining and
gymnastics really and my instructor is
like he's in Cirque du Soleil and he's
amazing and one of the things I say to
him before a class is like let's do
upside down stuff because I need to look
at the world differently and honestly
there are just days where I'm like I
just need to see everything upside down
I need a different perspective I I love
that you shake things up you always have
and your energy and enthusiasm are
fantastic and thank you we have all
learned so much from you we've gained
insight into techniques that have been
around some for a long time and some
that are newer that can help us be not
only better communicators but better
critical thinkers and I appreciate that
and and in conclusion I would just say
best of luck with your new book
talking to you is like a master class in
like you could check the boxes of all
the excellent tips and strategies that
you use that we teach people to use in
effective communication so it's great
talking with you thank you so much for
having me thank you and flattery will
get you over yay
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB
foreign